there's a drought of leadership in
Africa their leaders were trying at the
moment but a virgin co 4 is making some
efforts in in n'gana Brad and Becky is
also making efforts in South Africa but
I think we have a drought of leadership
because what we want to see in Africa is
a leadership that has vision and a
vision that will make Africa respected
but because we ask for respect but we
respected because we become players that
are globally competitive and also
leaders that can unify the intent of
Africa under globalization the survivor
is defined by regionals of rarity super
nationals of renting continental whites
of rank that says let's work together as
regions let's get to work together as
Africa because numbers make a difference
on a globalization we can't compete with
European Union s babo a South Africa we
can't compete against the Chinese and
Americans is small countries we can
compete as regions tzedek equus mcrib is
the AU so this notion of regional
integration this notion of pulling all
sources together we need leaders in
Africa or driven by regional sovereignty
and we've had leaders we've talked about
this for example I'm a Croma you know
here this false but in 96 to when they
drafted a constitution they stayed in a
court we as Africans are prepared to
surrender our sovereignty in part or in
total in pursuit of African Unity an
accord that's the kind of leadership one
in Africa leadership that is driven by
pan-african sovereignity and that moves
away from national serenity so no yes
their leaders are trying in Africa but
we have a long way to go in terms of
having that vision that is based on
technology and science
vision best on regional sovereignty and
that will make Africa a respectable
continent on this planet earth